we've talked about this in other videos
but just as a review things like visible
light or
the x-rays used when you go to the
doctor's office to see what's going on
with your bones or the microwaves used
to heat your food or the radio waves
used for communication that these are
all really the same phenomenon which is
that they are all different types of
electromagnetic waves and the main
difference between them is their
wavelength or their frequencies we know
that the longer the wavelength the lower
the frequency and the shorter the
wavelength the higher the frequency
now what's also interesting about
electromagnetic waves is that everything
in the universe that has any temperature
at all which is most things in the
universe will emit electromagnetic waves
you might look at yourself right now and
say wait am i emitting electromagnetic
waves well you're probably not emitting
visible waves you're reflecting visible
waves that's why you can see your hand
but your body is emitting infrared waves
now just as almost everything can emit
waves waves can also be absorbed
depending on the material depending on
the size of the object
now generally speaking when
electromagnetic waves are absorbed by
some substance it's turned into thermal
energy you can experience that go
outside on a sunny day wear a black
shirt and a black shirt is not
reflecting much visible light and so
it's all being absorbed or most of it is
being absorbed and it gets converted to
heat you will get much hotter than a
friend who is wearing a white t-shirt
now we have to be pretty careful as we
get to higher frequencies than visible
light ultraviolet light that's what's
causing sunburn and the risks only
increase as you get to higher
frequencies like x-rays and gamma rays
with these really high frequency
electromagnetic waves can do is knock
out electrons from atoms which would
ionize them which would change their
chemical properties that could affect
dna it could affect other cell tissue
and so that's why it could cause cancer
or just even kill cells if they get
strong enough